so in an effort to add more fuel to the
Charlie is secretly an old man fire I've
spent the last week here in the Canary
Islands specifically on Gran Canaria
where the majority of the other holiday
goes here are at least 30 years older
than Emily and I I didn't plan for it
but I have found myself on a holiday for
old people these these guys have
absolutely no interest in going wild on
vacation and kind of unsurprisingly I'm
very happy to be a part of this crowd
in fact sometimes the people here
actually seem younger than we do on our
first night here everybody was dancing
by the pool to an Elvis impersonator
while we were off to bed at 10 p.m.
complaining about the noise almost all
of my time here so far has been spent
eating reading and napping and it has
been great I would have spent more time
exploring the island but honestly it
seems as though this place has been
built specifically for eating reading
and napping in spite of not doing much
exploring here though I have found a
number of other things to marvel at
mainly the breasts there are a lot of
breasts out in the open here in fact I'm
pretty comfortable saying that the
amount of breasts real-life breasts I've
seen in my lifetime has quadrupled over
the course of the last 7 days or so this
is the point in the travel vlog where I
would show you a montage of all of those
breasts but I'm not gonna put you
through that don't worry I haven't been
recording obviously now while eating out
all the time has obviously been super
lovely one thing that hasn't been so
nice is that for some reason every
single place to eat here has a man
outside it yelling at you telling you to
come and eat at his restaurant right
this moment I mean I guess it's a tactic
the must have worked at least once on
somebody because now everybody does it
just in case it works again you can
never let them down right away either
cuz they always start with a question
like hey do you like eating I mean yes
yes I do but not with you hey where are
you from tell me where I'm not from
hungry I wish I'd said that to them but
I wasn't brave enough now we have ended
up doing one big activity while here
called Astro GC which was awesome a man
came to pick us up
in his van took us to the top of a
mountain at nighttime and we went
stargazing the high mountains and the
lack of light pollution here mean the
Gran Canaria is just really good for
stargazing and so thanks to that me and
Emily can now say that we have seen
Jupiter and its moons the remnants of a
supernova
the Orion Nebula two star clusters and
two galaxies and not only was it an
amazing experience that I won't ever
forget but it also makes me quite happy
that I have seen something slightly more
spectacular than just a lot of breasts
on this trip anyway this is the bit
where I meant to relate the galaxies in
the sky to the the breasts that I've
seen on this trip and turn it into some
lovely metaphor about loving yourself
and you're a star but honestly I can't
move it I'm on holiday so I'm not gonna
adios amigos you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
thank you very much for watching here in
my past two videos
one's about sex one's about Britain if
you can guess which one is which you'll
be in with the chance of winning the
grand prize of watching one of these two
videos ooh
I'll leave the rest up to you good bye